probably not the smartest thing to do to
be honest so that's why the blog has
sucked okay so this is definitely a next
evolution for me
[Music]
one believed nation welcome to day 7 of
my West Coast adventure I am very burnt
out late night last night I met Michael
salts nerd I think that safety has his
last name for the first time and one of
the things that was really interesting
in our conversation we spoke for I don't
know 40 minutes or something yesterday
late was he said that I care so much
about people and when I see something in
them I can't let it go
it's like I'd make a great marine
because I'd never let it go I'd never
let it go and it's my greatest strength
my greatest weakness and it's true like
if I find something about somebody that
needs to that they're missing something
I have to help I have to I'd like at my
own expense and then this morning he
wants me to check out his his youtube
video that he's just launching this
channel trying to get it up and he sends
me this video and I've got like no time
because I have to get ready to do an
interview right now
but er then I spend the next 25 minutes
watching this video giving detailed
feedback like seven different points
away should be doing as well I can't
help it
it's your greatest shame 3 greatest
weakness so I'm burnt out I'm rushing I
got to get a coffee
probably some water and then do my
interview let's coast here we go
this is the setup for getting ready I'm
about to do lunch we got lunch in here
but first another interview it's
interview time Tate o'clock dinner time
it's like 11 o'clock at night for me
Eastern I have not I don't know what I
film today I have no idea what I film
another insane day I shut everything off
to be here with the people barely
chicken on anything and just I don't
know it's probably not the smartest
thing to do to be honest but I just sit
down in the middle of the busy room and
just help and it's 8 o'clock everybody
well not everybody most of the VIPs went
to some fancy dinner I'm gonna do the
same thing I did last night
I'm going to subway get my turkey sub
with avocado and just go back sit in the
middle of the room eat my sub and people
will come and talk to me and I'll end up
helping them my voice is starting to go
I'm feeling a it's in my throat I've
been popping advils today physically I'm
I'm spent but mentally I'm not feeling
it you know like I for whatever insane
reason just want to go back and keep
helping I don't know I just if you have
the ability you have the responsibility
it's like the thing that keeps going
through my head if you can than you must
and I can't so I must so I'm gonna go
get my dinner go back to the busy room
last night I thought it would be just me
by myself doing it and then I ended up
meeting people and talking to I forget
what it was one something in the morning
so they might be the same
that's the best tomorrow is a light day
I don't know what's happening tomorrow
although I don't really know what was
happening today either I sat in it on
one session today I woke up early went
to do my video interview and then hung
out in the lobby and looked at my clock
and it was 6 o'clock I don't know what
happened conversations help him helping
youtubers and just so many amazing
people that I badly want to see when I
have a disease and that if I see
potential in somebody I can't let it go
like they need to get it they need to
see in themselves what I see in them and
I can't let it go I have to push it like
I literally won't sleep if I can't get
them to see what I see at least see it
and then take some kind of action it's
been amazing like everybody I wish you
had filmed some of these things but
giving people challenge like cake great
like this is what you're supposed to do
go do this is a guy who has a job that
he doesn't like who's now making YouTube
videos and most of them he doesn't like
and he wants to be a motivational
speaker but he hasn't made a
motivational speaking video in four
months and he's posting other videos
because they get some views but he was
like doing it and it's he's setting a
negative pattern because the more that
he's crazy other videos that he doesn't
like but that work it makes him less and
less interesting to make a motivational
videos like stop doing that those are
fake views fake news they're fake views
don't do that and then go make a video
now now yeah right now like go there
make a motivational video right now and
he made the first one he's made in four
months and he felt great and then it's
just that rinse and repeat over and over
again all day long with different
and it's just it just it fills the soul
so my body is like falling apart but I'm
not feeling it yet taking me a head pill
and it's helping anyway thank you for
joining me on my walk it's good to get
that out I'm at Subway now I'm gonna get
my turkey sub shot with Nina and then
head back oh boy guys I am in trouble I
am in trouble I'm in trouble
it is it is - it's 2:00 in the morning
it's crazy it's - 158 it's 2:00 in the
morning it's five o'clock my time
I gotta be up soon I've got you know I
don't know why that I it's my fault
I just kept helping people and when
there's somebody I think I probably
spent like an hour and a half with one
person just can't let him go I had to
help him cuz he was struggling and
nobody nobody else helped him so I had
to help them I could if you have the
ability had the responsibility if you
can then you must oh but I guess at some
point you gotta look after your own
health - right I'm beyond that point I
also promised one of the guys I met it
was a video of videographer photographer
on the rise that I would meet him
tomorrow and do a photo shoot I got a
pack
look at that chaos and meet him morning
and do a photo shoot I am I'm super out
of it
so yes another great day yes it is
life-changing and amazing and I can't
even recall all of the fantastic
conversations and the lives that have
been very much altered overall like I'm
super proud of all the work here and
everybody that I've helped and I'm an
amazing amazing experience I need to I
need I need to learn how to
self-regulate better and look after
myself better for the next time this is
gonna really mess me up I'm loopy right
now but it was awesome all right
it is my last day on my West Coast tour
I am
fueling it entirely 100% drained of
everything did not take care of myself
on this trip
mostly from
Just Energy staying up late every night
helping entrepreneurs and waking up
early to do something again but I'm
pumped to go home and get back to my
usual routine this morning I am meeting
a local entrepreneur named Jeff who is a
photographer and we connected really
well and he he had some awesome shots he
took shots of me when I was on the stage
and then I said hey I want to hire you
to do a photo shoot for me so I did a
photo shoot there's also some good
summit stuff happening so probably
enough meeting people and hanging out
and singing hi
hit the airport have to fly to Houston
stopover come back to Toronto and then
see my flight I have to leave here at
11:00 a.m. Pacific and I get in if
everything goes okay at midnight Eastern
so pretty much all day on the plane
hopefully I'll be able to sleep and
maybe do some work because I am
massively behind let's go
there is Jeff their photographer cheers
man Cheers
this is what we're doing this is it this
is where we're taking the shots hear
that that's the mad genius we're we're
in a new spot I'm gonna be right here
basically doing that that's it that's my
new shine look at way bud all right
we're gonna give it a shot
this is our last shot we're here for
filming oh sorry
I think he wants to get something with
this in the background no maybe not
I don't know we'll see last round here
we go the epic shot is coming
alright photoshoot done
Jeff is the main I wanted to have Jeff
on he's in the Y so this is the best of
all time my might have been flogging
whenever I chop live live but this has
been like the worst vlog of all time
awesome you have to be a part of that
yeah yeah because
when I'm here I'm here with yes you know
filming zero and still like I'll do a
little bit of b-roll and then I'm in my
hotel room it's like well I had a great
day and like so many conversations and
missed it all didn't record yeah yeah
and like that right and then the same
thing the next day yeah so so Jeff was
one of the guys that what we did for I
didn't know you before we saw each other
now right
okay and we saw like yeah yesterday was
the first day so so can you explain from
the other side because I've been
chairing like this is amazing work like
I just I have to stay up I have to help
I can't let them off the hook
but can you explain like the other side
they're going through you yeah it's
torture it's it's insanity it's it's he
goes from points to points that you
don't think about often and and makes
you realize that probably stuff you do
think about way in the back your hand he
just says no you you're right bring them
forward and then do that and stop with
all the noise and all the other
insanities that you bring into your life
and slow yourself down and confuse
yourself
and get to the point and
like when you ask certain questions
he's serving a purpose and is to lead
him through your story your life and for
your particular
experiences and then it helps him define
in order to help and who doesn't have
that definition in you you know how can
he do what he does and so the more you
give to him the more I think you could
get out of him if he's willing to share
that time with me I'm willing to get in
there
so that's why the blog has sucked okay
because well all had experiences have
been awesome a or you couldn't have seen
them right so I wish I would have
recorded right come on man yeah well I'm
a photographer not a videographer anyway
so so that's the other side and thank
you guys for kind of bearing with me
through these events it's know that it's
having a big impact on the people that I
am individually talking to and not
sharing online with you guys okay we've
got one more story what might have been
just a two-minute what can you tell me
about my youtube channel turned into an
hour really deep conversation about
where I am in my life and that's going
to have the biggest impact on now
[Music]
I think rarely conversation that went
that deep and that was that on point
is really grateful
[Music]
got to la LAX I'm late
I couldn't leave everybody want to say
goodbye I'm easy problem to have
so I gotta check in check in check in so
I get my flight need to go home and see
my wife you see my wife
[Music]
all right I am off to my flight I am
hitting Houston first and then Toronto
playing about midnight I think I told
you guys that maybe not I don't know
what the why there wasn't a direct
flight err but the problem was but
anyway this is what it is my initial
intention and coming down was I wanted
to finish my book and I started on the
way down and I think it got to like page
84 or something
there's 254 that I had to get through I
did no work on the book at all when I
was here I spent every waking moment
pretty much with people I'm behind on
every single project yeah I mean great
experience just kept getting stopped and
it's awesome but now I got to finish my
book so I'll probably switch between
doing the book and sleeping trying to at
least rest close my eyes I've probably
worked in like half-hour chunks and then
start to get tired and want to pass out
so I'll close my eyes and then wake up
and I'm working another half hour junk
and keep going till my brain is fried so
I think it's like a five hour flight or
something can't be that long Houston I
don't know whatever so let's see how far
I get let's see how far I get let's see
how far I get and finishing the book but
time I get the trial keep you guys
posted
[Music]
okay so interesting amazing flight
experience barely got anything down on
the book maybe five pages or so did not
sleep because the guy next to me
coughed every eighteen and a half
seconds it's the best much you feel bad
for him my throat hurts and I can't
imagine five hours of coughing every
eighteen and a half seconds is crazy but
I had a good thinking moment what I
realized was the obsession that I had of
the event where like I wake up at 7:00
go downstairs talk to people didn't go
to any single event any workshop at all
just talking to people look up in my
clock at six o'clock go get dinner come
back talk to people look at my clock
it's 2:00 in the morning it's just crazy
the time flew and just non-stop helping
entrepreneurs and I realized that's not
healthy but how much I love
helping people one-on-one and how I need
to do it more and so I started come up
with a plan to shift my schedule to do a
morning in Toronto in person live stream
with an entrepreneur I'm thinking
Instagram live I haven't worked out all
the details although by the time this
goes up it's probably already launched
to do a morning session Monday to Friday
9 a.m. to have me help an entrepreneur
through whatever they need to go through
and we're gonna Instagram live it up and
hopefully it inspires other people too
so now when you find the thing that
you're in flow on you might be you might
do it to the point where it's unhealthy
but it's the thing that you know you
need to you need to keep doing and so
this is definitely a next evolution for
me and it's scary and here's Hugh's
another interesting a little bit I
started getting scared on the plane
thinking about my schedule in the
calendar all the people that would
impact and and I was all in on the idea
and then and I started getting a little
scared of it and because I felt me
myself leaning away from it from the
fear then I had to take immediate action
then even though I didn't have internet
on the plane I emailed everybody on my
team my email because it impacts all
their schedules to when our plans I
emailed two people three people to be my
first people who I do the interviews
with I wanted I want to do it Monday
I mean it's Friday now to mean they want
to get home so it's weekend and then
Monday and I start so it would have
started by the time we you guys see this
for sure and so that's the thing like
you go to event you get inspired and you
meet somebody you get inspired you want
to take action and then you wake up the
next day and like if you don't and then
the next day it's gone
and so I felt that leaving I felt that
leaving me and so I had to I had to make
a statement I had to make a claim I had
to let everybody know here's what we're
doing so it's forcing it I have to do it
I've told my team I'm doing it I reached
out the three people to be my first
three so it's forcing me to do it and I
think that's good because I think too
many people get motivated to get excited
to get all fired up wait too long feel
the fear and as the fear comes then they
delay delay delay and the fear gets
bigger and they fall back into their
normal patterns and habits and lifestyle
and then and then that boldness is gone
and so like immediate action I'm
obsessed with momentum and as soon as
you feel yourself losing it you got to
bring it back up so I'm still tired as
anything I seven that any work on the
book but pump now I gotta get to my
flight don't miss it so I can get home
to Toronto also walking around with this
on my head because I had it on the plane
and I was gonna take it off and put in
my bag and a little tiny piece like
three and a half percent of the reason
why is because said I can't wear this in
the airport that's embarrassing because
it's a little bit of judgement you got
to eat that judgment eat that judgement
all day long so I'm wearing this until
he got in the airplane just because
and knock you late yourself against
judgment
[Music]
the landed first went off the plane
Oh quick tip guys look you got a life
you got an option here stairs
our escalators with a third option
walking on the escalators life in the
fast link
[Music]
now I'm coming from don't cut me five
min remember this I hired him what am i
coming from Los Angeles and come from
Los Angeles I'm my t-shirt it's gonna be
cold outside but it's okay I see them I
see them oh it's cold
embrace the cold wind off breathing
it's the Nina it's a tear oh look at
this guy alright get his team out it's
just an idea look at them and look at
this one who's that it's Nina
hello Ducky's hello thank you hello
wifey hello I see she's a good like here
oh my kid I said I could write you so
we're back oh my goodness did you miss
me I'm gonna still didn't believe nation
miss Nina for the past couple weeks I
think we did hello just Ana hello hello
hello hello good girl huh okay okay
thank you for joining us on our trip if
you want to see the crazy day that I had
yesterday from like 6:00 something a.m.
to 2 a.m.
check out the right if you want to see
that check out the link next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to I will
see you there